[Musik]
wasser feuer so dass jetzt endlich aus
wie die materialschlacht bin ich hab ich
recht genau damit kennt sich aus mit
materialschlachten auf jeden fall kann
wir haben hier ungefähr zwei esslöffel
olivenöl das brauche zum fleisch
anbraten dann haben wir ungefähr 500
gramm hinterhalt fleisch seine rote
zwiebel positive schmecken meiner
meinung nach besser schmecken
also da haben wir drei zehen knoblauch
dann haben wir hier 2000 stücke tomaten
gehackt tomaten genau und bei den
gehackten tomaten aus der dose da müsst
ihr euch keine gedanken machen dass sie
nicht das nicht gut sind oder oder
schlechter sind als als frische tomaten
bisschen wirklich nicht weil jeder meine
ernte direkt eingefroren
auf jeden fall haben wir hier ein
bisschen chili krise sogar zucker
oregano genau und haben wir hier 250
milliliter 200 200 milliliter
gemüsebrühe genau und zwar aber einfach
das rezept immer kohlen von der seite
genommen und einfach ein bisschen wasser
zwar ein gemacht wissen gemüsebrühe
pulver rein gemacht und haben wir hier
nur rigatoni und zwar regazzoni haben
wir 500 gramm und salz und pfeffer genau
dann haben wir hier noch einen kaffee im
café keese warum ich sag's euch ganz
einfach der kassa käse der gasag ist der
ist nicht so art wird sich wenn wir
jetzt nach hause genommen hätten oder
mehr ist er mehr milde gewürze trennen
der messe und gewürzen keseling parmesan
oder sowas dann wäre es einfach viel zu
salzig nach
deswegen wirklich in coolen charaktere
in eine kontrolle schmelz 1 geschafft
habe ich recht genau
also dann fangen zu erscheinen mit dem
hackfleisch habe ich ihm raten genau hat
fleisch anbraten
das kriegst du ja auch noch hin also das
hat gleich zum anbraten der olivenöl
beim olivenöl da scheiden sich die
geister manche sagen man sonst so
handeln benutzen
manche sagen das ist egal und ich bin so
irgendwo zwischendrin und sagt einfach
das ist egal
genau dann nehmen wir das hackfleisch
also erst einmal kurz ganz wichtig eine
pfanne immer langsam erhitzen und dann
langsam nach
nicht dabei sind macht sie den schwenker
her sondern ist gekommen habe ich recht
genau
also ich früher mal so erhitzt oder so
ich habe da zeitraffer machen ich bin
froh dass wir kein bewegungsmelder da
haben wir sogar ein bewegungsmelder
haben wenn man es nicht angehen will
erst so langsam das ist nicht mal ein
belegtes registrieren würde und die
gemerkt wenn es wenn ihr topf die
richtige temperatur hat das hat gleich
noch ein bisschen halt verschreiben um
es dann blasen gibt gibt's noch nicht
ist noch nichts wenn es einen blasen
gibt dann ist wirklich hat die pfanne
die richtige temperatur
hier haben wir eine super knoblauch
reihen dicht hinter so jetzt hat das
fleischgericht die temperatur ist die
mittlere stufe und es ist ganz ganz
wichtig beim pakt sprachen da machen
viele viele fehler
die hauen das ganze hat vielleicht auf
einmal rein dann zieht das ganze wasser
aus dem fleisch dann als wir so eine
suppe das heißt immer nur die hälfte
erst mal rein
die hälfte rein und jetzt zeigen was
ganz ganz tolles und zwar maximal
richtig drauf kommen das ist jetzt
richtig blöd mit dem er hier das zu
machen
jetzt war nämlich folge jetzt hole ich
den wecker und der weg hart da macht es
mich so sehr
das gesehen wahnsinn was ich alles kann
wie habe ich mal gesehen der wecker auf
das nennt sich der hacker so jetzt
warten wir in den rest rein und ich
werde wieder mit dem wecker seht ihr mal
wie hackfleisch struktur jetzt ist keine
klümpchen jetzt kannst du gerade noch
dazu perfekt aber du hast gelernt mir
messerrücken was machst du jetzt will
genau darum ist mir rein gemacht weil
das ziel ist richtig heftig bei uns so
machen wie der hand kein problem gut
deine finger bleibt wie deine haare die
sind so haarig so ein bisschen salz und
pfeffer
[Applaus]
und zwar ganz ganz wichtig immer richtig
coolen selbst gemahlenem pfeffer und
jetzt noch salz
jetzt kämen die tomatensauce mit drei
mit dem mit dem knoblauch company beim
reden ja jetzt doch genau der
zwischenzeit und käse reiben und zwar
ist das ganz einfach gelegt gemüse ja
genau so und jetzt auch gemüsebrühe ja
man muss ich gucken dass wir alles
frisch machen so doof sind wir zwei
jahren das nicht so ich bin so glücklich
dass ich dich habe ich dann zu sagen es
ist mir eine ehre an deiner seite steht
das ist wirklich wahnsinn und das wirst
2 und fernsehen geschafft habe ich
niemals gedacht du kannst gut lügen so
zwar kurz die produktplatzierung und
zwar nehmen wir hier den transformer so
einen käse oben rein treiben einfach
noch ein bisschen druck schießt es auch
der wahnsinn haben
jetzt können wir alle noch leben
[Musik]
das war wahnsinn oder hammer so günther
jetzt geht es weiter im winter und mit
mir bin ich was machen jetzt wollen wir
die die auf genau jetzt brauche die
auflaufform und zwar bekommen aber die
auflaufform nehmen probleme erstmal
[Musik]
sollte
wir brauchen echte antreten ist auch
sellerie reingemacht kein gemacht
brauchst alles nicht je nach geschmack
ja so jetzt in unserem special
auflaufform welche größe hat diese
plattform da ist auch immer meter start
war nicht mal 30 schüttet ja 20mal 30
auf nach vorn so klar nicht folgen
treten im guten tag zusammen und zwar
neben wir diese soße hier und man sie
rein und wenn alles schön in die
auflaufform rein
[Musik]
ich immer gerne wissen wie es war nicht
alleine machen werden die zwei schaffen
es kam zu zwei sehr gut
so wird vielleicht auch alleine schaffen
aber jetzt haben wir die null
ich weiß gar nicht warum wir es machen
kann ich einfach nur wegen der optik und
zwar stellen wir die nudeln rein hab ich
recht und zwar das soll ja eine torte
geben und zwar jetzt wisst ja auch warum
die nudeln tortellini heißen eisen
regatta nicht okay sonst komme jetzt
einmal zwei stunden später müsste man
ein großer heller raum wird genug ja das
was machst du auch täglich an einem
arbeitsplatz gerne kommt noch so ideal
wie geheimnis denn ich weiß jetzt schon
so einige blöde instagram einfach dass
es nur toll aussieht
dabei lernen areal ist im mund gab
wir haben wer macht so was wie eben auf
die idee kommen freut sich so das machen
was hast du jede sagen das ist was man
isst gewinnen
warum kann die person die das nachmachen
foto macht und zeigt wie sie es gemacht
hat kennt die person wie auch gleich die
telefonnummer schicken wir sie gern das
macht mir ja echt person geleitet werden
ersten gespielten ist guck mal da kommt
mir kommt noch so eine idee das sieht
auf den bildern immer so toll aus und
dann
[Musik]
wichtig ist dass die nudel möglich in
der so ist dass sie natürlich hart
werden
das ist ganz ganz wichtig und jetzt
kommt natürlich käse oben dann machen
wir das was darf ich jetzt mal in meinen
händen meinte günter wack der backofen
von anderen und ist kann man auch machen
erstmal nicht und zwar ich zeige nur
warum das muss mal rein
[Musik]
so richtig cool den kassen darüber
normalerweise tut mir jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen ungefähr bei 200
grad so ungefähr 35 bis 40 minuten
wir machen etwas ganz ganz anderes weil
wir haben was ganz besonderes
das zeigen was wir jetzt machen wir
nehmen die aktion und zwar gehen wir
hier auch die assistspunkte es ist wenn
von banken keine ahnung hat dann gehen
wir auf aufläufe wenn es ist ja ein
auflauf zeigt und dann haben wir lasagne
frisch ablauf bekannt auflauf süß mit
einem auflauf bekannt okay im auflauf
bekannt dann macht hat er noch ein tipp
was sagt der gefäße aus zwei höhe zwar
ist in der mitte sagen okay somit muss
jetzt sagt er zu mir den wassertank
füllen und zwar für den massen können
so ist er kurz den wassertank zack so
wollen rein fertig habe ich gemacht und
jetzt leute von der ley de 44 minuten
perfekt 170 grad passt sich perfekt
eingestellt und jetzt schauen wir nach
was rauskommt und auf 235 bis 40 minuten
ja es ist von je nach backofen ist
unterschiedlich wir haben aber ja auch
nur 170 grad zum beispiel ich habe
vorher gesagt oder 200 grad unter
oberhitze und jetzt guck mal was
passiert zwischen zeiträume mir beide
einfach auch mal sauber
[Musik]
murat morath sally jederzeit kannst du
zum probieren kommen
ich weiß nicht polizei war wohin klar
auf lauf lauf
das ist immer gut aus herzhafte lacher
navigatoren und im stehen um das lose
okay ich hab dir alle einzelnen stellen
warum es gibt den messen wir legen ein
motto gestellt wie es kommt gespannt
lecker mit hackfleisch sieht gut aus du
bist im rat jetzt wahrscheinlich noch
mittagsschlaf das konzert ist für dich
so einschlafen sieht aus wie lasagne nur
halt nicht quer sondern hoch ich gucke
ich hab da auch gemüse drin wobei punkt
nicht fragen was der vorteil ist man
braucht gar kein messer man kann es ja
gerade so und kohle
also ging galt männer männer sind halt
gelingt das rezept auch wenn man die
nudeln einfach drauf legt und natur
hochkommt die soll manager
ich bin zwar nicht fest salat
feldsalat dazu macht video abschluss mit
einem orange und das angst irgendwo sich
auch fragen ob sie den kanal übernehmen
[Gelächter]
lieber morath wenn du das war wirklich
seine kaufmann ich weiß gar nicht wo er
steckt aber mir wäre ich bestimmt gleich
finden um die franz wild bleiben weil
diese listen live view und ihr fallt ihr
das rezept namen volt und glaube ich mal
stellt dem rad auf salehs - blog.de
da schreibt jedoch immer mit oder oder
macht es seien absurd
wahrscheinlich wird noch irgendjemand
schreibt das konzept für euch weil murat
hatte die kategorie oder ich hab die
kategorie erfunden damit die gebissene
freizeit habt und der morath mir arbeit
abnimmt leiter der rezepte selber
schreiben also ich finde sehr lecker
könnt ihr gerne nachmachen wird zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]